this streamer is now over $10,000 in
debt and it's not even his fault what
twitch content creator coconut B
recently shared a screenshot that showed
a $27,500
donation which was later refunded
leaving coconut in some serious
financial trouble where is my money
turns out donors refunding their
donations is becoming more and more
common you made me shave my head bald
shave my
eyebrows to refund I can't tell if
you're joking because if you're being
serious why would you give me more money
to ask you to give you your money back
it may not be a huge deal for some of
the bigger streamers out there but it
definitely hurts the little guys